hello this is Adam from PlayStation
grenade I'm not you really want to
speculate on unconfirmed leaks or even
write the hype train so to speak but I'm
going to get on board this time and make
an exception because this is potentially
exceptin e2 and I quite like destiny two
images of horses rather looking like
they're from Italian origin have worms
their way online with a potential
release date for destiny to sep tember
the eight 2017 get it in your diary now
we can brick down the two bosses and I
believe that these are legitimate first
the iconography is correct we have a
hunter we have a warlock we have a Titan
wielding new weapon one of which looks
like a serious regime in shotgun forum
the trouble can be seen in the
background and the whole aesthetic
carries over between the two forces we
also see the word beta what is the icon
in the top right corner which is making
me make this video and it also makes me
quite bloody excited this blue logo
looks like the exclusive content image
that playstation like to use what could
this mean well in destiny one
playstation was the only place you could
go to experience the full dessin again
we regularly receive additional weapons
and armor and missions and early access
to many areas of the game could this
leak sure that this will happen again in
destiny to a little more digging online
reveals the potential bit of dirt coming
in june with the ps4 reportedly
receiving early access yet again this
comes directly from Eurogamer so this is
a pretty reliable source what do you
think to the news do you fancy joining
me when the beer to drop and what would
you say if I told you I wanted to make
more destiny content on this channel let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below and I will see you next time
[Music]